la sociaux tech le concept d' idéologie
cours de sciences sociales la première
question que l'on peut se poser est
qu'est ce qu'une idéologie une biologie
c'est un discours sur la réalité
un discours qui est fait de
représentation et d'idées je veux dire
préconçues milieu j doit apparaître
comme un discours cohérent
c'est à dire qui a du sens c'est un
discours collectif il est partagé par de
nombreuses personnes
ils divergent cela de l'utopie qui est
plus individualisé c'est un discours
systématique
c'est à dire qu'il repose sur quelques
principes et il s'organise autour de ces
principes d'une manière vraiment
cohérente qui le transforme en système
qui ne laisse pas la place quelconque
possibilité d'en sortir
c'est un discours rationnel qui se base
donc sur la logique sur la raison
et c'est aussi un discours partisan car
il réfute toute autre possibilité
d'explication
lorsque l'on parle le discours partisan
on peut développer cela par différents
éléments
c'est d'abord un discours qui diffère du
discours scientifique pour rappel la
science par la mise en place de
certaines méthodes de certaines
procédures et d'une rigueur indéfectible
va tendre à décrire le réel les
phénomènes qui peuvent être observées
d'une manière la plus objective possible
ici nous ne sommes pas dans un discours
scientifique lorsque l'on parle d'
idéologie puisqu'il s'agira à tous les
coups de donner raison si vous voulez à
l'idéologie et non pas au réel
c'est un discours qui par la force des
choses et simplificateur puisqu'il var
par hbo reposer sur quelques principes à
l'exclusion de beaucoup d'autres et il
va ériger ces principes en sorte de loi
qu'ils ne seront jamais démenti ou
battue en brèche
c'est un discours manichéen puisque il
va distinguer ceux qui ont la bonne idée
au logis de ceux qui ont une autre
idéologie
si vous voulez il y a vraiment une
guerre entre les différentes idéologies
et donc du coup le monde est séparé en
deux ceux qui ont la raison ceux qui
croient ou dogmes et ceux qui sont sur
une autre idéologie
enfin c'est un discours dissimulateur
puisqu'il va évacuer toutes les
explications tous les phénomènes qui
contredisent l'idéologie principal et
les principes qui sont à son fondement
actuellement il ya trois grandes
idéologies le socialisme le nationalisme
réactionnaire et le libéralisme
nous allons d'abord abordé celui ci le
libéralisme a pour point de départ le
postulat suivant le marché c'est à dire
la rencontre entre l'offre et la demande
pour une marchandise est capable en tant
que mécanisme anonyme d'auto réguler les
rapports économiques entre les individus
chaque individu en poursuivant ses
propres intérêts contribuerait à la mise
en place de l'intérêt général comme si
une main invisible
agissez tel que l'a théorisé adam smith
en 1776 ce dans les recherches sur la
nature et les causes de la richesse des
nations
rechercher à augmenter le profit
personnel contribuerait donc à la mise
en place de l'intérêt de tous le
libéralisme pour ce faire présuppose la
propriété privée et la marchandisation
de la terre du travail et de la monnaie
le libéralisme repose aussi sur la
consécration de l'individu et de ce fait
ces fondements sont et théoriques sont à
chercher dans la science économique et
en particulier dans la micro économie où
chaque individu est supposé à avoir un
comportement rationnel
la psychologie sciences qui sacralise
également l'individu sera également
mobilisé par le libéralisme l'idéologie
nationaliste vise à instaurer un régime
discriminatoire à l'encontre des
individus qui ne sont pas considérés
comme appartenant à la nation l'état
nationaliste entend établir une
différence de statut entre les nationaux
et les non nationaux le fondement
théorique de cette idéologie et l'idée
de nation qui est perçu comme une entité
durable découlant de la nature des
choses
de ce fait le nationalisme s'appuie sur
des disciplines comme l'histoire et
l'anthropologie pour justifier
l'existence de la nation comme une
réalité quasi transcendante qui s'impose
aux sociétés et aux individus
le nationalisme conduit à l'instauration
d'un ordre juridique aux politiques qui
sacralise les frontières nationales
glorifie les symboles de la nation et
assure la préférence nationale sur base
de l'antériorité ceux qui étaient là
avant ont plus de droits que ceux qui
sont arrivés après même la nature vient
justifier ces différences l'état nation
est perçu comme un objet naturel et
évident qui s'imposent le nationalisme
est dit réactionnaire cas là il vient en
réaction au cosmopolitisme et à
l'effacement des frontières
faisant suite à l'avènement du
libéralisme comme idéologie dominante à
l'échelle mondiale
le socialisme postule que la société est
un tout chaque individu constitue une
fraction inaliénable de ce tout chaque
être humain est interdépendant avec le
reste de l'humanité
et si l'on intègre la dimension
écologistes qui est une idéologie dérivé
du socialisme cette interdépendance
c'est en a aussi à son environnement
la question de l'égalité est donc
centrale pour les partisans du
socialisme pour assurer cette égalité et
amener chacun à s'intégrer idéalement
dans la société l'éducation apparaît
comme un rouage essentiel c'est
l'éducation qui autorise la mobilité
sociale elle-même garante d'une société
inclusive équitable et pacifié où chacun
a une place comme pour le nationalisme
réactionnaire le socialisme vient en
réaction à la domination idéologique du
libéralisme mais la comparaison s'arrête
là car l'antinomie entre le nationalisme
et le socialisme et réconciliables au
niveau de la question égalitaire l'un
établi des différences sur base de
l'appartenance nationale tandis que
l'autre entre voit la dimension
universelle de l'humanité comme pour les
deux idéologies précédente le socialisme
s'appuie sur différentes disciplines
le soubassement théorique du socialisme
sont les sociétés sciences sociales
sociologie en tête qui vont permettre de
détricoter les évidences nationaliste la
nation comme une construction est une
construction sociale et libérale le
marché ne peut pas tout par une grande
entreprise de dévoilement comme marx
durkheim et bourdieu l'ont fait à
différents niveaux et à différentes
époques
cet exposé est terminée la bibliographie
qui a servi à sa préparation socialisme
et sociologie de bruno karsenti et cyril
lemieux ainsi que le dictionnaire de
sociologie aux éditions hatier bien sûr
si vous avez apprécié cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à visiter la chaîne la
société que vous trouverez d'autres
courent sur les sciences sociales mais
aussi la géographie
vous pouvez éventuellement vous abonner
à la chaîne et si vous avez apprécié
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à nous mettre
le petit pouce bleus
merci et à bientôt